[Music]
[Applause]
Mark Sanchez Fox NFL analyst former
quarterback he was on the call the
Giants and the Raiders yesterday in Las
Vegas joining us on the program what did
you expect out of that game going into
it that was uh that was a wild one hello
good morning Dan good morning danet um
you know so we get the the privilege
when you call a game you go in on a
Friday you watch Friday practice and
then you get to interact with some of
the players and the
coaches and there was U an energy a
juice around the building there was
something you could feel and um you
didn't quite know what it was so I
attributed it to you know the change
over and and turnover that happened
during the week um with the head coach
GM and all that but you're like okay
well how how long is this going to last
last and what does this actually mean
because a lot of energy is great but
Just Energy going in all different
directions that isn't focused on
executing on the field doesn't really do
it not at this level in college you can
get away with more of that in high
school for sure it's all momentum and
you figure it out but at this level
you're like okay what's that GNA get me
and I figured right after the first
quarter that's where I'm going to see
what this Raiders team is all about and
it's still only one game but this kid
Aiden o Connell I mean gave him plenty
of time number one I think the play
sequencing by Bo hardigree was perfect I
think they still struggled and and
nobody said anything they still
struggled getting the ball to Devonte
Adams he he barely had an impact on the
game if any at all really they threw him
a couple quick throws or whatever but he
wasn't a major factor wink marale and
the Giants took him completely out of
the game the problem was you know they
lose Leonard Williams the week before in
a trade and Josh Jacobs went off I mean
he finally hit the Sentry Mark and goes
over 100 yards he ends up taking a loss
so I think he ends up with just shy of
100 yards but that was by far his best
output at one point you know him and
saquan were averaging like seven yards a
carry I'm like dude just snap him the
ball whatever you got to do get it to
number eight this guy's you know
unlocking everything you need in your
offense and making it Easy by the way on
your rookie quarterback from Purdue that
is making his second start and in his
first start it was rough so whatever you
got to do and and Bo hardigree knew it
and felt it and then the defense comes
up with two turn turnovers Daniel Jones
Goes Down And then I mean the route was
on and it was um it breaks your heart
for Daniel Jones um but you see this
Raider team and I mean you see all the
clips from last night I mean these guys
are like smoking cigars in there like
they just won the Super Bowl it's like
whoa pump the braks a little bit but I
can understand obviously that speaks to
you know this new found almost like a
weight was lifted off their shoulders
and and it's um you never like to see it
with coaching change and all that but
that's the way it goes and the guys
obviously responded and how about
Antonio Pierce like La guy you know just
total Raiders Kings like I just picture
him in the 80s and 90s growing up with
that Raiders starter jacket you know
like the Compton hat you know bumping
Dre on his you know speakers like that's
that's who he is and it it was like
perfect for him and um you know the
postgame interview like just yelling
Raiders like you could tell they've just
fired up and they haven't had that
excitement in a long time so it's fun to
watch if you're the Giants are you
looking at moving on from Daniel
Jones well I think they'll they got to
figure out what's going on with the knee
it sounds like
ACL um and if that's the case you know
we're past the deadline it's like what
are we going to do to try and Salvage
the season how soon is Ty uh Tyrod
Taylor back which is what three more
games are we rolling with Tommy DeVito
and then
longterm um what's the plan there so uh
I I'm not totally sure on the contract
structure I know you know it was a big
number
andu yeah this year and next year I
think they're locked into that so I
mean I wouldn't be shocked if they if
they you know try and build up the team
around them but the team that they're
building up around them has to be
available okay they've they haven't had
their bookend tackles for a better part
of the Season or at least playing
together they've had just as many
offensive line combinations show up
quarterbacks in and out Darren Waller
was supposed to show up and help that
tight end position he's been in and out
of the lineup Bellinger the other tight
end from San Diego State he's been in
and out of the lineup it's like you know
sure does Daniel Jones need to protect
the ball and not you know force it at
certain times when everything looks bad
yes 100% And he's owned that but I mean
come on man you got to help the guy out
him saquin like you know saquin was
going off yesterday too but you're down
20 something points at halftime it's
hard to run the ball it's hard to just
turn around and hand the ball off
there's not enough time and um so you
know I feel for the guys with the Giants
and and the defense is really starting
to pick it up these last couple weeks
generating turnovers and all that and um
but once you lose your guy like that
that's makes life tough your uh Alma
moer fired the defensive coach Alex
Grinch um we're just do him in Gloom
today man yeah I know but I'm Wonder
about this though you can fire the
defensive coordinator you still have the
same Talent there is this a question of
the scheme of the defensive coordinator
or is this about the players that
Lincoln Riley brought
in uh I mean I think there's blame to go
around just like anything I think um you
know and this is what you sign up for as
a coach at this kind of level you're
going to get scrutiny and if things
aren't going right at a program like
this then people are going to want to
change and it's unfortunate that's the
way it works so is it players is it
scheme and that those are some questions
that they're gonna have to answer um I
can see I mean we definitely could use
some help up front I think on both sides
I think that's that's where our next
step will be in my opinion is is
snagging some of those big dudes that
that end up going to Georgia that end up
going to uh you know Bama those kind of
you know big guy I mean you got to
control the line of scrimmage and right
now um you know we're getting moved
around and not moving enough so it's um
and it's it's difficult it's hard to
play complimentary ball like that when I
mean it's a 50p point shootout every
week yeah you know and and I've never
been a part of you know not a spread
offense like that like that air raid
attack Mike Leech kind of
stuff but I mean you're scoring fast
your defense is on the field a
lot um it feels like every every game's
like 50 to 49 I know a couple of them
have been that way but that's I mean for
me as an offensive guy like if I was
calling the plays I might have 10 heart
attacks every game you know like I I
can't whoa like hey we got to get a stop
man we gotta get a turnover we got we
got to do something but I gotta dial up
you know 100 touchdown passes a year
like good Lord that's I mean that's a
lot of work so I just uh it's a
different style of football and it's
more of this new age style because it's
so popular in high school it's easy to
teach easy to coach easier to understand
for a lot of these players and that's
why you know the the transition period
when you get some of these guys from
college that go to the NFL like trying
to get them to figure out this new
league is a little different but the
league changing with it as well so gosh
back to this defense sorry that was a
long word salid answer but yeah some
some had to change and it's unfortunate
when it goes down like that but bottom
line is these players got to execute you
got to put them in the right positions
to execute Sanchez Fox NFL analyst how
is CJ stad making it look so easy geez I
this kid looks unbelievable I'm I'm like
hoping we get a Houston game coming up
we haven't had much of him or like when
you watch games in study for teams there
hasn't been a ton of Houston crossover
tape for whatever reason and it happens
that way but these highlights you're
seeing I mean this is like he looks so
calm and so comfortable and they're not
asking him to do anything
like that he's uncomfortable with
they're bringing him along every week
right and now he's to the point where
you know you're looking at some of his
stat lines you're like gez guys are
chucking around the yard man with a guy
who's who's barely done this so clearly
he's got the confidence clearly they're
bringing him up the right way and
educating him along the way and giving
him a little more you know kind of SPO
feeding him early let the Run game go
you know some easy completions he's got
veteran guys like Robert Woods I can't
tell you how important those types of
players are especially in the slot um
having Dalton Schultz that they got from
Dallas uh sharp kid uh Stanford kid I
want to say but like route running
ability and giving quarterbacks
opportunities to throw to open players
so not every throw is contested not
every throw has a chance to get tipped
intercepted boom there goes your
confidence a little bit these guys
are
you don't you don't know you know it's
hard for me to to say because I'm not
listening on the headset but like that
whole operation the you get down to the
six yard line you have it's like a
Calamity of er they had a penalty uh a
FAL start like sack take a sack the sack
was that was a bad sack number one it's
a fourman rush I understand those are
really good pass rushers but I mean Dak
barely hit his back foot got one look at
something and then boom he had to move
I'd prefer if he moved up in the pocket
and my only question on that on that
particular play was the week before he
hit Ferguson against the Rams down the
seam right down the middle and threw it
on the top shelf like right on the top
of his helmet in that situation you have
no timeouts there's like 20 something
seconds left you're running about maybe
three to four plays depending on how
fast you can do it and if you're
inbounds or out of bounds whatever
incomplete complete that matters but
that was a play he showed me and it's
first and 10 now's your time to take a
shot like you got a chance you're taking
you're just dropping them in the end
zone trying to figure it out and he had
him one1 and in those situations bottom
line like if you're CJ stad in a
situation like that it's where's Schultz
where's Woods if you're Dak it's where's
CD lamb and where's Ferguson those have
been your best
targets get the ball to those guys
bottom line is at the end of the game
it's Johnny's and Joe's not the X's and
O's find your Ballers get them the ball
that's that's really what it is so I
think the Eagles winning um that game I
thought was huge for them and and
they're just really starting to separate
themselves especially with that Giants l
Lo they're owning that NFC East maybe
the first repeat chance in I don't know
how many years so that's uh that'd be
huge what do you have this
weekend uh we go commanders at Seahawks
okay how many times what wait how about
the rough in the passer because Vilma
was on that call I'm excited to watch
that game I know it's Commander Patriots
but the rough in the passer on M Jones I
was I I watched it and then py goes yeah
roughing the passer was called I go
how he tried not to land on I'll protect
quarterbacks all day long okay you need
those guys on the field to score points
and make it all work and I get that I
I'm a proponent of that but come on man
he didn't even land on he barely hit him
knocked him down and then like did
exactly what they said he rolled off and
didn't push off of him on the ground and
I mean that was as clean as you can see
Vilma was on the call and I saw one of
the clips of it I think he does an
excellent job though by the way for Fox
but I I get a good defensive perspective
when I hear him uh markare I get a good
offensive line perspective you know so
sometimes when I have those crossover
games I love watching those guys but
Vilma was like wait a second and he came
from you know he's older than me so he's
like he's like that old school you know
take the quarterback's head off and
worry about it later so that was bad
they should let these quarterbacks today
watch highlights from the 60s and 70s
and understand what roughing the passer
was because this well remember the
the um wasn't it a segment on ESPN like
you got jacked up or whatever it was
yeah those were like you know Punt
returners and guys catching like a
little bubble screen and just flatten
them I mean they got hammered and
so I don't know I think it's called you
got fined that's the new segment on ESPN
is you got fined for that with the
little meter and how much money how much
it's going to cost you there hey hey
we're on to something yeah this is good
yeah save travels play nice with Pete
Carol always
always you wouldn't criticize don't
start anything don't start anything why
you always I know I don't know I didn't
mean to I just thought you know what are
you going to be overly nice to Pete on
the broadcast as opposed to have
somebody read into it that no I've I've
I've gotten on him before uh with some
of the silly penalty week one with DK
Mecha and the silly penalty he had
towards the end of the game when I said
that's not a coach Carol deal he's going
to be upset about that they got to take
a good look in the mirror and they can't
do that they can't afford whatever so
I've I've been critical of him and you
know you got to play it straight you got
to play it straight can't have uh can't
have favorites I'm always you know to a
fault rooting for the quarterbacks and
rooting for the offense but I do
appreciate good defensive plays and good
coaching and stuff so what's the uh do
my best man what's the commitment to the
hair what are we uh what are we what are
we going with uh you know I'm not 100%
totally sure um maybe it's our next poll
question and then we just decide what
the new hairo is we Shave It Go Mohawk
nice high top fade dark Caesar like
where are we going with what does your
wife
want she's down with it she oh she is
little flip little curl
little it would look good if you're
playing now out of the helmet coming out
of the back of your helmet yeah okay
that' be good what uh I saw wink Martell
for the game he goes hey look at that
flow you got the Tennessee mud flap back
there nice Tennessee mud flap nice I
never heard that you're mullet uh sa
travels good to talk to you as always
thanks for joining us appreciate it guys
we'll talk soon that's Mark Sanchez
former NFL quarterback now working for
Fox he's got Seattle and the Commanders